it's my
pleasure to introduce peter wang from
continual continuum analytics
and and thanking continuum for helping
us organize and host this wonderful
event here at facebook
so peter holds a ba in physics from
cornell university and has been
developing applications professionally
using python since 2001
before co-founding continuum analytics
in 2011 peter spent
seven years at nthot designing and
developing applications for a variety of
companies
including investment banks high
frequency trading firms oil companies
and others in 2007 peter was named
director of technical architecture
and served as a client liaison on high
profile projects and he's also
developed choco and open source python
based toolkit for interactive data
visualization
so let's please welcome peter and what i
hope will be a very very interesting
talk
all right thank you everyone um so first
i'd like to um
give a great big shout out and a very
warm thank you
to facebook for hosting us this has been
a fantastic venue
and let's just give them a big big big
round of applause
so hope everyone has had a good time
here has learned at least one thing
um maybe two or three um and what i'm
gonna talk about today is
well it's it's kind of a it's a
wandering talk but it talks about a
number of different things
but overall the the the theme is about
pi data the past
and the present and then the future and
where we're going to go
so um so i think maybe the first
question would be to sort of ask you
know how do we get here
like why are we why did facebook open up
their campus for us
how is that we got you know hundreds of
people here to talk about all sorts of
great stuff
um and if you look this is these are
some photos from two years ago when we
did the first
sort of python data workshop and that at
that time google stepped up they gave us
uh
a couple of rooms in their headquarters
and provided free food it was
fantastic um and then julie steel is
julie here
she you're somewhere maybe she doesn't
want to be done well there she is she's
in the back
julie really um helped out tremendously
by by putting all that together and
coordinating
uh wes was also uh you know an organizer
and and myself a continuum and we just
got basically
you know i sort of saw this need to
organize
to organize users and developers around
the topic of
python for data analysis so it's deeply
connected to scientific python we've
been having these scipy meetings for our
conferences for a long time
but i definitely saw there was a
different user community around this
data analysis space
um so basically what we did is we
emailed a bunch of our friends you know
who are devs in the sci-fi community we
got
some other people registered and we just
had a really great time
and one of the things uh you know we
just come
from exhibiting at the strata conference
uh which was also which is santa clara
and um
and julie also helped run that um and so
travis
uh my co-founder got to see firsthand uh
that was his first contact so
first exposure to what the data analysis
or what the big data and data science
community looks like
um and so you know the year before i had
gone to strata
which was the first strata 2011 and i
walked around and every single vendor
was talking about hadoop
but every single tutorial and
practitioner was talking about python
and r
and so um so basically you know travis
saw this now 2012 and he gave a
at the pi data workshop he gave the room
full of you know our friends and fellow
developers and users
um he was giving this talk asking
questions like you know what is the role
of python in the space um he put up
controversial pictures like
uh you know snake swallowing elephants
drawn by by princes
and all sorts of crazy talk like python
could be
a pure dsl to c plus on top of the lvm
infrastructure
um and so uh so things like that but
one thing that was really cool was that
uh guido who was working at google at
the time
uh came by and chatted with us and so he
took a bunch of questions and a panel
format is really very friendly of him
um and and so here you see sort of i
don't think it's quite this conversation
but i'm just sort of you can imagine
right
um travis saying look
you know please help us convince the
python core developers this again 2012.
um you know please help us convince the
core dev to to work with us on solving
the packaging problem
uh and and guido um you know he takes a
lot of requests from a lot of people as
the creator of the python language
and he gave us he had a really great
response he said you know
eh you know fix it yourself and um
and and so so sort of like okay
challenge accepted right
um but but actually some of you might
you know sometimes i talk about the
packaging problem some here some people
here i think know what that means
but a lot of times especially like on
hacker news or the python subreddit
you sort of get this like what packaging
problem right so you people are like
well i just use
pip and virtual lens and it works great
or i have homebrew on my mac
um you know rpm and app get any gen 2
users
right i just untar some things or i
double click an msi file
maybe i just make some stuff or i like
export a python path to a git check
out and if you do these things or you
know for those sorts of users
i i feel sort of like it feels sort of
like this
you know sort of like you're you're
it sounds great it sounds great but um
actually maybe more appropriate would be
something like this
because um the instant you need to run
your code on any machine that's not your
machine
or on your machine three months from now
um you're going to run into a problem
so more seriously i guess um this is
what i sort of mean by the packaging
problem
uh this is kind of a warning for any of
the old-timers in the room
this slide may actually trigger some
like ptsd but um
but basically packages you know didn't
actually exist in the python language
design like in the beginning
and they were added sort of you know
later on and guido sort of has never
been that particularly interested in
them and i think it sort of shows
but i've been watching python since the
beginning of this particular evolution
you know like 99 is when i really
started using python
and so i've sort of seen this unfolding
so you know this is uh
i've seen this sort of unfolding sort of
like this train wreck
in slow motion except it's multiple
train wrecks
where one train comes in grabs the
previous train
backs up and plows in again so um and
that's sort of this what this picture
shows um sort of like well we'll we're
gonna use setup tools but no actually
it's gonna be distributed or dis utils
we're gonna fix that or
well everyone's using pip now and so
that picture right there is actually
around 2013 i think is is sort of like
um there's some pun here around
train wrecks and wheels but i couldn't
put it together but anyway you guys work
that out
um but the question is how many people
here i'm just curious how many people
here understand that picture
okay how many people here want to
understand that picture
seriously all right i was going to say
because i was i was expecting no hands
and i was gonna say here's the quip
all the people who would otherwise raise
their hands are off at the bar crying
into a beer
so so you have that so in a sense when
guido came in and said you guys fixed it
we were like okay that was actually very
liberating
okay because we took him on his word and
we created anaconda
and conda and we're like now we're good
right and so whatever happens
in python we're still you know we keep
in touch and everything and i think
they're aware of what we're doing
but it's still one of these situations
where uh the scientists and
the data analysts and pi data and the pi
data and sci-fi communities understand
the needs much much better i think than
core dev really did so
um so anyway kind of backing up a little
bit
then um overall that was kind of the
initial kickoff that was
literally at that workshop is where
travis and i sort of looked at each
other and were like you know we should
create a distribution and create some
tools to make this better so that's
that's the beginning of anaconda and
condo was right there
um so then you know in the subsequent
two years we've had a number of very
very successful
conferences leah leah can you stand up
raise your hand
she's not going to stand up leah has
been absolutely instrumental in making
all this happen
um but the dirty little secret is when
you email admin at pi data it goes like
to her phone
so it's uh so so but this is also you
know a
a community coming together a community
of users a community of developers
people um stepping up to organize people
stepping up to get their companies
to like you know foot the bill for
sponsorship or to provide a venue
uh jp morgan in in october of last year
gave us this gorgeous space
uh in their in their big skyscraper and
you know in the financial district
so um we're doing it again this year
actually if you look october
uh in july we have um berlin in october
we'll be back in new york
um and we'll have sort of two events one
we're gonna have a pi data day
uh kind of as part of the strata
conference if you're going to strata
that just look look out for that
something you can do
we're still finalizing the schedule but
that's something that's in the works and
the other thing is that um we're gonna
do another
new york conference in october but we're
looking for a home so if you have
friends who own companies and
skyscrapers uh in new york be sure to
get in touch with leah
all right so um but that's how we've
been kind of going so this is the first
two years
uh which is actually a short amount of
time you're doing all these conferences
growing this community from like a room
full of people
to the kind of very very large
population we have now
um but if you back up a little bit more
and you say well that's just the the
conference itself right but really pi
data
builds on top of the tools from the
scientific python ecosystem
so you know in the last 10 years these
are the sorts of tools that have come
around right so ipython notebook
was really officially released in 2011
but there had been work
around this area since like o5
and then pandas as wes i think i have
the timing right on that but i think he
started in oa but certainly the first
public release was sort of towards the
end of 09 scikit-learn 07.
numpy itself actually is relatively new
2006
which is still less than 10 years ago um
but of course numpy
uh and all these things build on top of
scipy right which started 99.
uh ipython was 01 and matt paul lebo 2.
like you know there's actually a lot of
deep history in the tools that we're
using now
it's really interesting to go and teach
python to people and all this is so new
to them
it's like this is actually really mature
technology um you know millions of
people banging on this stuff
it's in production everywhere and
actually one thing i should mention if
you are using matplotlib
if you if it is you know if it's
actually useful for you and your work
you should go to numfocus.org john
hunter and contribute to the john hunter
memorial fund um you know john started
in 2002 as labor of love he's you know
shepherded the community throughout
his time on the project and so it's
definitely something you should do if
you use matpotlib
especially if you give like kickstarter
campaigns random stuff like you should
kick in some money for the for the fund
so
um anyway so backing up even more 20
years right the last 20 years what's
happened
uh you can actually see that the the
origin of the use of python for
scientific computing and numerical
computing
is very very very long so num array
was started in 2001 um and it was sort
of a
light fork or sort of a uh i guess it's
basically kind of a fork of numeric
which started in 1995
and nomura numeric were two very
different that different sort of things
they're optimizing for and they were not
really compatible
and so people had things like the
numerix library how many people here
actually remember numerix
we've used numerix yeah a few people
right that was a terrible time i was
actually say
if nama ray and numeric um if that rift
did not get merged that would have
fundamentally forked
the ecosystem we would not be where we
are today and so when what travis did in
2006 with numpy he spent the year
building numpy
that that basically pulled these two
halves of the world back together
and then everything else all the
innovation since then is i would say to
some extent been possible because of
that unified
um cohesive library but
if we go further back then let's just go
all the way back right like when did we
so he looked so happy in that that's his
wikipedia picture he looks so happy in
that picture
it's taken a while ago um so python
python he actually started python as a
weekend project in 89
released it publicly in 91 out of cwi
and then
and version one was actually it was
until several years later in 1994
and that's 20 years ago right um
actually if you uh if you look
so uh when he talks about it you know
he'll talk about the history of python
he'll say that actually it was inspired
by abc and settle which of these
languages that that were being worked
out at the time
abc was at least at cwi but he wanted to
make something like that that appealed
to unix and c
hackers now if you want to see what that
looks like you wanna see what version
one looks like you can actually conda
install it so we made that
as an april fools not joke um
uh just a you know a month ago and so
you can you can do things you can
actually look at the blog post
um just as a warning there's uh there's
no lists there's no dictionaries um
there's no bullying constants and
there's no read line so you can't press
up and down
all right so good times um but if you
look again like what is this abc thing
abc
uh if you look at the wikipedia article
again it's uh it's interactive
structured high level
intended to be used instead of basic
it's not meant to be a systems
programming language
but it's intended for teaching or
prototyping right so this is actually
very interesting because this means that
python
has its roots in the teaching language
it was inspired by teaching language and
it's actually one of the only
modern languages i think uh language
modern application development languages
to to be able to make that claim like
pascal delphi you know pascal was sort
of a teaching language delphi
is used in some places um scheme i don't
know how many people use scheme
production though
vba small talk that's true
um but again it's a fairly small uh
adoption in terms of like across
mattering languages now
and vba is heavily used but it's so far
derived from basic that it's kind of
hard to make that connection
but i would say that this is actually
again a really important point because
if you look at before the zen of python
before import this before one obvious
way to do it before
you know all of these various things the
creator of the language
uh was was basically doing this by
design he wanted to make it accessible
by design
and actually i would say throughout the
evolution of the language that design
guidance has remained fundamental to a
lot of the decisions a lot of the no's
and some of the yeses actually behind
what's grown python as a language
so when we see efforts like software
carpentry we have universities switching
wholesale
their cs curriculum to python um you
know we have boot camps like the women
technology boot camp that happened
yesterday
all of these things where people are
teaching people how to program with
python
that's not like sort of an accident it
actually was somewhat by design
and there's this great saying i like
that um it says any idiot
can write a program that even a computer
understands
okay so the key thing to right and the
key thing about python is that it's a
language that affords writing programs
that other humans understand
that's actually a really important thing
who knew um
not all humans are mechanical turks
either so so for the non-mechanical turk
humans maybe
um and so many of you probably heard
mark andresen's quote that software is
eating the world and i i really
fundamentally believe this right
because computers are obviously they're
everywhere they affect every aspect of
life every corner of the planet
uh other planets if you guys saw rob's
talk yesterday uh
nasa jpl uh relying on software to drive
cars
uh you know on mars and to control
satellites out beyond the edge of the
solar system
actually um i would say that it's
probably the most badass cloud computing
is you know the oort cloud computing
um but uh but one sort of there's a
different twist on this too which is you
know software eating the world sounds
really great if you're a programmer
but the other thing to be respectful of
is that when software meets the world
the world also changes
software right the world is is starting
to make software
uh and when the dust settles certainly
the world is completely transformed
but the practice of software itself will
also be transformed
and so how many people here out of
curiosity how many people here do not
have a degree in computer science
but do write software as part of their
day-to-day job
and that's the world eating software
right that's the other way around
so the users are really hacking the
asylum in this case we're not just
waiting for the gods of cs to deliver us
stuff we
are just making stuff ourselves um and
and the the there's actually this wasn't
always possible right back in the day
computers
and languages used to be really hard
this is a 1979 book
really really great uh bedtime reading
actually but it's about the boroughs
5000 and the people who are there
uh and in this particular excerpt it
talks about this guy the author who was
meeting um this like college kid named
don knuth
who claimed that he was gonna come and
bang out an algol compiler in the summer
and none of the people believed him they
just didn't believe he could do this
for like five thousand dollars who's
gonna do this he needed magnetic tape
not punch cards but he would just build
this algol compiler
um and so they started asking around
about this kid and
apparently the scuttlebutt was that the
kid had already written the compiler
so it was already done and so anyway um
but what's funny about this is that like
it took a canoe to write a compiler
and no one believed he could do it
whereas if you um saw the the keynote
talk yesterday
like you can just build dsls on top of
python in python
and you can use disk and ast and you
know by play all these various modules
to transform the language and build your
own you know make it your own
so compilers aren't that hard anymore
and and i think building
compilers and dsls is actually going to
be something that pythonistas are going
to have to get more comfortable thinking
about in general
one of the main points of my pi data new
york keynote in october
was that really the hardware and
software stacks of the last 20 years
they're no longer serving the needs of
business computing
we've been told that sort of you know
has traditionally we have each of these
different layers of abstraction
there's languages and there's different
ideas and different sort of concepts to
think about at each level
and then you know the experts at the
hardware level provide us
these these low-level languages and then
the experts there will write
language runtimes for us and then
finally we as the pros at the top will
get to write scripts that make these
things do useful stuff
but that tower abstractions is really
really broken um
and i guess in some sense you can think
of the i i think of the cloud computing
and
the the big data disruptions both
fundamentally
arising from the brokenness of that
model but on different ends of it
so in my view and our technical view of
continuum is that we'll get better
performance and better productivity by
staying at the higher level
and then compiling downwards and it's
not just
us if you look at other languages
whether it's a javascript and shadow
classes and va and jit
compilation whether it's the jvm lots of
other places are doing this
so this is again not a bunch of
theoretical hand waving right so this is
um
you know two two instances here uh
adroll um
and the deluworl architecture they're
using number the compiler
uh that we have a continuum they're
using that in the middle to take python
code and then put in the right in the
middle of their high performance
analytics stack cloudera just this week
came out with a blog post talking about
using number to compile user defined
functions
for impala written in pure python
compile those down to machine code and
running them and they run
as fast as the the c or the java
equivalents
so so this is real right um
and so like back in back in 2001 this is
a very kind of embarrassing for me to
actually reveal this but
i posted on complex python right about
what are some of the best development
practices
and there's there's a whole thread that
went off about
static typing as you would imagine but
uh the thing is that
paul rubin had this really great quote
that he says
you know sometimes python can be used as
a workhorse sometimes it's a racehorse
but neither fits in a glue factory so
this idea that python's just a glue
language
um and then tim peters came back and
really liked it even winked at it
so so the interesting thing now though
is that actually i think um we
we're in this interesting space where
being a polyglot language being
something that plays with other
languages and other runtimes that's
actually an integral component of
performance
so this vision of python is glue 2.0 uh
it turns out that like the
the glue horse works like pulls harder
and runs faster
um but i think that metaphor doesn't
quite work so anyway but the idea here
is that this is sort of the technical
rationale for our darpa work
um the x data work that we're working on
blaze is really sort of that bulk data
descriptor and then number as a compiler
engine
to allow python to talk to other
languages and other runtimes
and and i think this this kind of vision
you know it's going to take a while to
get there
working on it we're making really good
progress but certainly you know it's
it's a it's a work in progress
um so let's switch gears a little bit
talk about data science right let's talk
about the hard problems and data science
that people are using these things for
um there's there's sort of a lot of
there's too much uh i think
discussion out there already about the
hard problems right you know every
uh every middle manager will say like
the three v's and they'll kind of like
mug at you
um but uh so we already know all this
stuff there's lots of data there's lots
of computers and just a whole bunch of
different tools new tools every week
i'm not really going to go into detail
on a lot of this stuff
i will just say that i think most people
to first order most people say big data
when
when their excel blows up and that's
that's kind of when they start thinking
like looking out the world at the world
of big data
um but but for people in this room right
i mean
we know there's something real here um
there's there's uh
it's sort of this very new and different
thing this idea of a data-driven
business
and strata 2012 i think it was i heard a
plenary talk where
um it was really fantastic actually this
idea that data
will become substrate i think it's
really that probably resonates with a
lot of people in this room
and i i really believe that i actually i
believe the world is very much on the on
the edge of this on the cusp of a data
revolution
if you will um especially you know here
where facebook uh we're you know looking
around all the practitioners here from
all these different companies big and
small
it's very easy to believe right in the
middle of it but i think it's actually
just beginning so if you think back to
like 96
and what it meant to be an internet
troop believer then um
you can already see kind of the shoes
starting to drop right like the web was
a few years old already
93 is actually when the aol put all of
their users on the internet
the term of course for that is eternal
september right when the internet
started to suck
um 94 is when steven sinovsky a cornell
alumnus
sent an email off to um it's an email
after bill gates and said the internet
is live and well at cornell we should
pay attention to this thing and bill
gates is like oh okay consumer internet
um and that's when microsoft really
started to pay attention to that so
uh 95 java was released as a network
operating system you know for the web
and just for the network so
by 96 it should have been pretty obvious
to people that there was no going back
every business pretty much recognized
this um and again it's
it's not an option it's not like oh it
was nice to be it's an option it's not
an optional thing if you don't
then you will be destroyed um and i
think we've seen that play out in the
last you know
gosh almost 20 years and so i think
we're actually in a similar spot in 2014
relative to the concept of a data-driven
business and what that means
so you know in the sense of like i don't
care what your business does whether
you're drilling for oil whether you're
grooming pets whether you're
you know shipping postcards around
fundamentally if you're not data driven
then in a few years time it's just a
matter of time some other competitor
that is data driven will come and
destroy you and take your lunch
so um i guess as i was saying like 2011
is equal to 1993. uh maybe in javascript
that's true i don't know
uh they don't have integers they use
floating point you never know about
precision problems
but in any case i think the idea for
those for those who are there those who
know the history of that i think you
sort of see the
these things happening right so um so
there is a real opportunity
here um and and instead of talking about
the hard problems data science that sort
of
are in the way of those opportunities i
want to talk about the soft problems
now it's actually probably the the
biggest or the hardest meta problem
is really that there's the multiple
disconnects between multiple things
uh multiple many different groups of
people so um
so i'm calling them soft problems
because i think they're they're really
they're about communications
fundamentally um not you know any
particular chip getting faster
so if you think about the traditional
model of business computing you have a
bunch of double e's making computers for
you
you have a bunch of cs graduates writing
software and applications around that
so you don't have to go and toggle
switches on the computer um and then
you've got big data and you've got like
math and stats grads that are delivering
insights to you
um they put an excel notebook and then
a workbook and then they give it to the
the actual management you know business
decision makers
um and that's sort of that's that's the
happy world that everyone wants to live
in but that's
we all know it's not actually the
reality right the reality is that
um the traditional tools and those
abstractions as they break down
you end up with more and more of the
underlying abstractions leaking through
to the point where data scientists now
they have to understand the data and the
actual analytical problems and the stats
and the machine learning and all these
other things
but if they understand machine learning
they've also understand something about
gpu programming
right because now of course they know
about hardware i guess and then they're
also writing distributed you know run
times
um and so really uh in the middle of all
that stuff they have to then produce
insights to the
to the front end business uh business
decision makers
at the same point the business people uh
really want to get very agile responses
back from this infrastructure so you
have
this back and forth happening and you
have the data scientists sitting kind of
very much in the nexus
of this interaction um and it's not
really
that pipeline anymore and really i mean
it's it's painful to be in that spot but
it's also really amazing
right because if you're at the nexus of
all of this stuff it means that you know
you probably have a little bit of job
security
um and more importantly it's it's
actually probably the right way to run a
data-driven business
so that that gap
and all of those that multiplexing um
you know obviously
people here in this room would agree i
think that people are doing this with
python very successfully doing more and
more of it with python
effect because you really need a tool
that gives you fluency and gives you
confidence over your data problems
so i'm actually very grateful this is
the data science
salary survey that o'reilly put together
and published i think at the very
beginning of this year
but um you know what what you see there
is that python are neck and neck they're
above
excel in popularity above hadoop above
any of these other
things they're just below i'm not just
below but they're second only to
sql which is really i think eye opening
for a lot of people
but also reaffirming and validating for
us in the python community right that
you know
we've known our bet from two years ago
you know we had the first python data
workshop was that
python is a great tool for data analysis
even just using the scientific tools and
improving them a little bit and i think
this really validates that
so i'm actually kind of curious how many
people here have a background in physics
that's a lot of people that's awesome so
so i guess all of you will know very
viscerally right that physics is not
just math
you need to have sort of physical
intuition you need to have knowledge of
the domain but you also need to have
this kind of scientist mind
to to formulate good questions
hypotheses and so
um in the same way that i think math is
a language that that physicists use
to get kind of fluency and cognitive
mastery over their problems
i think python can be a tool for data
scientists to achieve mastery kind of
over their data computing problems
because data science is more than just
stats right it's it's about modeling
data using
computers doing really robust modeling
using lots of computers over a lot of
messy noisy data
it's actually kind of interesting if you
think about it that a lot of the
advances in mathematics
some of the major ones came from
physicists like they had to invent new
things
to solve problems that the previous
tools couldn't couldn't deal with so
like calculus for instance
and so i would say that software is
actually a cognitive tool as well
not merely an application that you point
and click and export to excel
so um you know that the point of
clicking kind of works for some things
but if you need a if you need a tool
if you need to actually have cognitive
mastery over a domain where you're
generating hypotheses where you're
you're thinking about new questions you
have to have you have to
basically be able to cook not just you
know select from a menu and so
uh one of the terms that i heard or one
of the the phrases i heard uh
pretty recently i thought was really
great was that python might not be the
best language for everything
but it's um but it's almost certainly
the second best language for anything
um and i tried to find the source of it
and i google around and turns out that
people said the same thing of c and c
plus plus
uh end of javascript and bash and perl
so
i'm just gonna stick with python but um
i'm gonna argue for why it's true for
python
maybe not exclusively true but certainly
true for python wait i guess it has to
be exclusively true okay well
um the idea here is that
the idea here is that i think it blurs
the line between user
and maker right so if you look again
i didn't put the names of the people
because there's just too many right the
community is actually very large for a
lot of those projects
but in the very first slides i showed
all of those tools over the last 20
years that people have built
um the in the pi in the in the python
scientific and data communities
the vast majority i would say almost all
of those tools
are built by by people who are users
um so we stand on the shoulders of the
users who became makers right so
uh something i hear a lot from people
who use r and people who are
promoters of r is that you know r has a
great user community
um there's you know any any statistical
algorithm you find in there but but also
there's just so many users
and what i want people to say for the
python community is that we have a very
strong maker
community in python because
unfortunately if you go and try to use
some of those things in the r community
you know like it's it's it's hit or miss
right uh whereas in python you know a
lot of open source projects
you're embarrassed if your docs are not
good people will shame you about lack of
tests
and that's okay that's good because it's
it's it's makers right it's make a
community of makers and users
there's again another really great quote
is this idea of course the science right
science advances because we stand on the
shoulders of giants which was a great
noble quote
and then the sad truth of course about
programming is that we stand on each
other's toes
and uh and so i would like to think
again about this idea of users becoming
makers is that in python we stand on
each other's shoulders
right this is kind of this community
that bootstraps itself
there's a really great quote kind of
back to this idea of writing programs
for people this really ties into that
right
um uh the the author of the little
prince has this great quote that there's
one variable problem and that is the
problem human relations i've always
loved that quote
and it is it is so true um it's just so
true in every aspect
as i get older as i do more things
interact with more people across a broad
spectrum
of areas i just find that that quote
validated over and over again
um and uh back in 2010
before before all this data stuff i was
still at anthony at the time uh at the
scipy conference i gave this um i think
the mother of all lightning talks
where i sort of hijacked lightning talk
slot it went off for 15 minutes
um by the end everyone was laughing so i
think it's okay but um
but i've been thinking about this
problem actually for a while like what
i'm trying to you know impress upon you
here is that i've actually even since
then i was thinking about
uh at the time i was like uh really
reflecting on
this is great you know we have a great
user community i was having a great time
at scipy meeting
all my friends and all the other people
in the community and i was just kind of
contemplating
um why are we here how do we get same
question i'm asking now how do we get
here what does the future look like
will it always be this way and what
happened at the time i was motivated to
give this lightning talk because i was
reflecting on
the the enterprise adoption of python
right python meets the enterprise is
going to be my the title of my talk
um and and what i i have slides like
this one i had slides like this like
actually not that enterprise this
enterprise um
i also sort of poke fun at java
programmers um
and uh and then you know i really
settled on this idea of like what is
what are things that are true about
python why do people like it
why why are all these um phds and
everything from
you know every aspect of science why are
they using it
and you know it was really interesting
if you go to
if you go to sci-fi i don't know how
much happens now but if you back then
every single person you know they could
be like you know a 55 year old
researcher from some national lab they
show up and before they give their talk
there's this long pn about how how the
much they love python how great scipy is
how much they want to thank the
developers
every single talk and so i was like this
is why do people love python so much
and so again prior to that conference i
spent a little bit of time working
through an enterprise python code base
that was
um for lack of a better term
un-idiomatic and
i don't think the authors of that
codebase would have gone on stage in wax
poetic about how much love python for
instance
so i wanted to talk a bit about the
python language about passion and
creativity all these things
um and i settled on these different
ideas right that python gives you
it has this this um there's this idea of
mastery
that if you spend a little bit of time
with it you get some stuff done if you
spend a lot of time
there's actually a lot of depth you can
get really really interesting
performance
um so you know the way a violin is
different than a kazoo
python is different than excel right so
um because
you guys see you you see like the a is
to be a csd
so the idea though is that additionally
because it's readable there's actually a
network effect
because the people who are really really
really bright and motivated
can get down and build cool things they
can be makers that then they can give to
everyone else they can disseminate
everyone else
and it's not a magical pile of pearl
it's actually something i can approach
and learn from and read i can read
how these other libraries i use and love
are written i can go submit
things to them and then i can grow this
community that network effect is amazing
so um i also talked about community
actually that was one of the things i
was thinking a lot about at the time um
and i sort of gave people this
admonition of you know things to do
right um
things not to do and um and really you
know encourage people there to be very
deliberate in how they introduce python
into their enterprise environments uh to
their friends and and
possibly frenemies um so that's sort of
that really is my fundamental point that
brings me to this idea of and the
subject of community
that uh four years ago right i was i was
focused on how do we grow the community
but it was just a sci-fi um at pycon
this year and actually
for the last however many years the the
same point is repeated um so how many
people here went to pycon
this year or have been the last couple
of years maybe
a couple three okay good yeah a good
number of people and and you'll you'll
you'll probably have heard this the
statement that python you come for the
language and you stay for the community
right
and that's it's just it's so warm and
fuzzy it almost makes you hate it
because it's so warm fuzzy but it's true
it's just wonderful
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with that it's just wonderful and so
what i want to see
is that i want to see us grow a very
strong data science community as well
and what i see looking around and just
talking to people is that there are a
lot of people coming into python picking
it up
um and using it for these data science
tasks a lot of new people coming in the
door
and what what they see when they go into
pycon for instance and see a lot of very
very welcoming people a lot of uh just
kind of like people people beating the
drum about community i want to make sure
we have that same
we established that same kind of ethos
here uh in in the python and data
science communities
um you know one thing that is so for all
of the goodness of pi con
the python core development community
actually you know they don't really know
a lot i think about
what we do in the scipy and the python
data world it's sort of a mystery to
them
um and and you know there's many cordets
who've never imported numpy or even
looked at pandas or
you know made a plot with matplotlib and
so um
it's not their fault i mean they're
working on a core language it's that's
that's what they do they're cs people
but in the scientific python world we
start to mind our own we have to grow
our own community right
you know one of the saddest things um
that i hear actually is
is when someone at a in a company or
maybe someone posts on
uh one you know somewhere on on some
social media or some linkedin group
um you know they're like well we're
interested using python but we're
probably gonna just use java because
it's so hard
to hire python programmers you know
there's not enough python programmers
out there and what they're really saying
is it's hard to hire good python
programmers
but you find lots of people java on
their resumes and just you know bring
them in you know but um
but actually but but the challenge
that's a real challenge for us right i
mean imagine if you want to go
and and build a python stack at a
company and you get pushback from people
saying we just can't hire python
programmers not enough of them
so if you want to keep using python if
you want to see python grow in its
adoption of various places we need to
make more python programmers and the way
we do that
is by having a welcoming community
having a community that that really
again bootstraps itself that reaches out
and includes everyone
so um you know i would i would sort of
you know i guess the the admonition here
um and the charge that would give to
everyone is to participate right
actually
step in and participate whether it's on
social media whether it's through github
whether it's through private email or
mailing lists wherever you
see python being discussed wherever you
see data science being discussed
step up and represent say i did this
problem with python
and all the other sas programmers will
be like oh you can do that with python
you know like there's so many
environments right now where people
simply don't know what's possible
um and and i'm i've stopped being
plugged into something because they're
so frustrating and they take so much
time
but you definitely you definitely know i
mean all of you know like as the world
of data analytics and business data is
being transformed
there are a ton of people whose eyes are
opening and looking around we want them
to see python and see how great it is
in the python world i'd also encourage
those of you who are in areas that
you find like-minded people to start pi
data meetups um
just even if you meet up for drinks or
for a quick lunch or something
it's great to make that personal
connection with people again back to
the little pro to the little prince and
and to antoine this exercise is actually
such a fundamental part of
of how we of everything but certainly in
computing it's
it's an under discussed and
under-appreciated aspect of it but the
really successful
technologies i think um that we're
seeing now at least in the open source
side they have very strong communities
behind them
and also of course i encourage everyone
to you know keep doing what you're doing
come to pi data conferences submit
talk proposals and i would also
encourage you to work hard all
everyone whether you're under a
represented minority or not to work hard
to increase our representation there so
reach out to
to friends uh and the people co-workers
and collaborators that you know that
you think are doing interesting work um
you know really lean on them to submit
talk proposals really you know try to
bring them along
uh you know and if if there's a need for
if there's financial hardship
if there's need for any kind of
sponsorship we do have diversity
sponsorships things like that that are
available to us
and through the psf and through our
other sponsors this uh
one of the things that actually is very
interesting again for those who went to
pycon is if you've been going for a
number of years
you can see the hard work uh done by
steve steve holden and jesse noller
all the pie ladies everyone there who've
been involved in increasing diversity
uh of attendees to pycon and speakers of
pycon what they've what they've shown
was
interesting this year they had a massive
massive um well
relatively massive compared to
technology in general but a really
really high turnout of
not only of attendees but also of female
speakers and i think in the years before
uh you know like eight or nine years ago
you could go and you could step up and
you could say well i just don't think
there are enough women here what can we
do
someone would say well there's just not
enough women in technology period i
think we're doing fine
and what pycon has shown that if you
have a sustained effort by the community
over a long period of time
you can absolutely change that and and
actually there are a large number of
underrepresented people are not showing
up
because of a number of different factors
and so i would encourage everyone in the
pi data community to think about how we
can
how we can you know improve and it's not
it's the hardest thing about
uh efforts like diversity outreach and
things like that is it's not like
one big thing where guido says now we're
gonna go to python you know like
diversity there's it's not that doesn't
work right it's millions and millions of
little things little actions sustained
over a long period of time and that's
what's so hard about it
i think it takes commitment overall from
the community from everyone
so i just really want to emphasize that
point we had a women technology
event i don't know how many people are
aware but we had i think something like
60 where's cindy i think
she was like 60 60 60 high school girls
showing up learning to program
programming python
um they they sort of sucked all of the
female attendees away parts of the time
to go and help but it was this really
amazing event in october
we did the same thing at jpmorgan they
brought in a bunch of female high school
and actually even some middle school
students i think and there was an
amazing uh you know sort of stem
and women in stem sort of event that was
getting people to program
for the first time you know getting all
these girls actually hands on keyboard
writing their first program it was
so empowering for them and just so
rewarding for the people who are
involved
so things like that i think are ways
that we can absolutely differentiate
ourselves as a community not just as a
technology
but as a community so uh just to recap
you know i sort of talked about how we
got here
and overall i think you know if you had
to distill it down to one slide
it would just be you know hard work hard
work a lot of um
so so that's the whole thing about
science advancing uh one funeral at a
time sort of morbid but true statement
um i think uh i think scientific python
and python data advances one
postdoc or tenure at a time sort of
people who you know
extend burn through a postdoc or burn
through a tenure to build some library
that everyone
loves so a lot of hard work but it's
hard work by a community of people
uh and it's people who actually cared
about the tools who cared about uh doing
good work for their
for their collaborators for people
thousands of miles away they've never
met before except
maybe over email and not only they care
about the people not only do they care
about the code right they care about the
people
so where do we go from here i think it's
pretty much the same thing right more
hard work
more community more caring more code
more people um and just more in general
and so the underlying point here the
fundamental the last thing
is this idea that we can talk about
python being a glue language
uh about it being glue 2.0 we can talk
about it being a polyglot environment
the
python forks new folks are doing great
work with having
ipython notebook be about all these
languages coming in whether it's r or
julia or what have you
uh you know in my my own project on
bokeh we have we we have
a you know a small interface now in
scala we're interested in having
uh a closure and r and and all sorts of
other sort of interfaces built to it
we're interested in python being
very much a polyglot ecosystem but
that's just code
right that's just python as glue code
what's really really important i think
what's equally if not more important
actually is that we want python and pi
data to be communities
so when we do scipy we invite the the
the developers of julia to come and give
keynote talks right when we do pi data
where
we welcome people to come from the r and
other communities
and share their expertise and their
perspectives with us so um
that actually for the this is a record
for the first time ever i finish
a talk with time left um which means i
must talk really fast
but uh but uh that really concludes the
slides and i don't know if there's any
any questions i guess we just open up
for questions and comments
wow nothing
this kind of more of a question going
back to beginning and talking about
numba do you ever see a future where you
do something like number llvm
and then maybe threw in script in the
javascript i mean a lot of people have
tried to do this right like how can they
write python and turn it into javascript
and run in the browser
from your experience like a continuum do
you see a future for something like that
for like using lvm as a glue between
python and javascript
yeah actually um i have lots of opinions
about javascript so
depending how deep you want to go down
the rabbit hole what i think is very
interesting um so
my fundamental idea about javascript is
that um
it is right now
let's see here what's interesting to me
i think the most interesting thing about
javascript development overall
is the emergence of asm.js and what
asm.js really says
is it's browser vendors and other
people who don't use javascript saying
hey we really like each other
and we have to go through this
serialization interface called
javascript
so you can imagine asm.js so those who
know or don't know perhaps asmjs is
a sort of a a way of writing javascript
such that you're hinting to optimizing
jitting
javascript runtimes so they know oh this
is an end this is how i declare an end
not by saying int like a proper language
by saying
this number and then like you know
bitwise and whatever
so you could use you can actually easily
do this with comments right i put
comment
i could have statically typed python uh
asm.pi
where i put a comment above every single
line and i give you like this full like
type
declaration for every single variable
right so you can do things like that
and so asm.js is i think the emergence
of it shows that there is interest from
both sides here that are not javascript
programmers
to build better bridges and i think
things like dart and typescript all of
these things are are basically saying
the browser is a great runtime but this
language
you know could improve so um using lvm
using numba
as a gateway to the inscription asmjs
sort of front end i think absolutely can
be done the big challenge
the big challenge actually in languages
is not so much the ast transformation
and the expression graphs but actually
the types and the semantics on the
underlying types
um so i think you know if we can
figure out nice or or what are
meaningful subsets
right that would actually be very
interesting because then that means you
can write browser
then what you could do by the way
numbers is written in python
itself you know for the most part um we
have a python wrapper around lvm
so there's no reason you couldn't use
inscription to compile lvm itself and to
compile number so that it all runs in
the browser
and then you type python the browser
which then compiles in the browser
to the browser right it's all fine i
mean it's just a runtime
but um the question is will other
languages get there faster to where we
actually have nice pleasant languages
that we can sort of sort of co-develop
with python
because i don't mind writing a little
html right i don't mind writing a little
css
writing like a bunch of javascript which
then i you know wrap in braces and
evaluate real quick
you know like that that's just a
terrible way to live so um
so that's the i said i'm opinionated
about this stuff but uh
but i i think you know the compilation
into the browser
is an area that yes you're right people
have been trying for a long time and
there's things like python right which
are just like subsets of python that are
maybe good enough
to run in the browser but again the
challenge is semantics of the underlying
types
and and how much are you willing to
limit that and what you can compile
there's a question i think raymond had a
question back there right
so i don't know if you guys know but uh
ladies and gentlemen raymond hettinger
is one of the core python developers has
created wonderful i mean just been an
integral part of language for a long
time
and so he has graced us with his
presence here at pi data uh today
so i'm
for a long time people have wished for
a matrix operator yes measures
multiplication yes what's it going to do
for us
predict the future
it will get more people using python 3.
i think um actually so matrix multiply
was one of the things that came up
there are three things i remember coming
up in that panel with guido at the first
pi data workshop
one of them was the packaging stuff the
second was matrix multiply operator
and the third was um this idea of
writing little dsls
like we want to write little dsl so we
want to do like i
you know everyone here is probably
familiar with the idea of pass by
reference and pass by value
what lisps and functional languages let
you do is pass by expression
right i can write a little expression
here and just pass the whole thing in
um and if we have a we really need a dsl
to kind of do this
and and that was something that guido
was thinking about a little bit but but
not really you know it was like whatever
for him but like nick hoffman for
instance interested in these kinds of
things ast rewrite
um so so of those three things though
what's interesting is
you know uh two of them have
materialized right so we made anaconda
on condust so now the packaging problem
is
basically well if it's too bold to say
it's basically solved but i think we
have a good lead
on solving the packaging problem and
then the matrix multiply operator got
accepted which is fantastic
um i think what it what it shows is
uh there's another talk i give where i
sort of talk about the history
of how great uh the python how python
and
numerical python have co-evolved so uh
basically
some of the things around slicing and
lists um you know building in complex
numbers there's no complex numbers
in python 1.0 but they're there now and
having complex numbers and having
actually a complex number type
means that everyone who builds libraries
and c extension modules around your
language
can agree on how they're going to
represent complex numbers which is
actually really really huge
and there's precision issues if you
represent polar versus representing uh
you know with uh
um i and and real but but the idea here
is that
the python language in general has been
very very receptive
um to the needs of the numerical
community so
i mean for me it's like the impact is
it's
it reaffirms i guess to a lot of the
scientific community
that you know python is as receptive as
it's ever been
um and um
i'm i'm interested actually to see well
like me i'm always interested to see the
abuses of it right i'm gonna see like
how people
overload one more thing to override you
know and under under
but um but overall no i think it's just
it's just reaffirming and revalidate a
sort of continual validation that python
is a great language for numerix
uh so i like your thoughts on tracking
the community and the ecosystem over
time
to a large extent the scientific uh
python ecosystem was sort of
bootstrapped
by sort of the c and fortran communities
and code bases
uh i'm sort of curious what you think is
going to happen 10 20 years from now
both both the scientific python and the
pi data uh community
and the code base what's gonna happen in
20 years
yeah so that's actually very very um
simple right
because i'm gonna be wrong no matter
what i say so i'll just go into it right
it says no
if it's like three years from now i i'm
gonna be called on it right but if it's
like 20 years no no one's gonna remember
but um but uh actually i do talk about
this the the the reason for my python
meets the enterprise talk was
um it was actually very simple i i was
sitting there can you see that you
cannot see that oh and what you do see
is my notes which are really
embarrassing
let's get that backdrop going on there
we go um
beautiful there you go nice logo um
the origin i see my presenter notes too
that's not so good
view show presenter notes anyway um
okay well so what i was talking about
the reason for that was because i was
i was there and literally in the shower
that morning of sci-fi i wrote that
lightning talk
that day when i was sitting in the
conference um some things never changed
and so that uh i was thinking like well
am i gonna be coding python in 10 years
am i going to teach my kid i just had a
kid in
about two months before that conference
and i was like am i teaching him
python or is it going to be squeak or
javascript or something right
um and uh and so i reflected on that and
i think
actually the the reason why i talk about
this idea of
um the writing higher level languages so
i think in this slide we have better
performance like better living through
chemistry right
better performance through high level
through higher level stuff
and the reason i think writing this
higher level
code is actually going to keep it
is actually going to be it's going to
stick around longer is because the lower
level stuff is what churns the fastest
um the higher level stuff the low level
stuff like
it takes a lot of engineering effort to
tape something out it takes a lot of
engineer effort to build an operating
system
and to build a language and a compiler
and a set of standard libraries
all those things take you know we have
increased lots of effort but
they're still fundamentally capturing
the expertise of people at
those levels it's very sort of
stratified but at the high end
you have like business expertise like
there's people still running cobalt
right like there's the stuff that's
still running on like the ibm like z
series mainframes
those things don't change because those
business needs actually
the the risk the downside risk of
changing those out is so high so python
is being used actually for more and more
production
stuff that's something actually as a as
a community
i think is a hurdle or not hurdle but is
the thing we're gonna have to figure out
because we love the dynamic agile
prototyping nature of this stuff at the
same time once you start rolling things
in production
we have to like grow up a little bit and
think about what does that mean for this
to run for five years and we actually
already see this
i see it all the time actually in
discussions about python 2 versus python
3.
and you know you have people coming in
and saying wow i can all see why people
don't just upgrade and
you know upgrade their code it's so easy
there's not much to do it's like well if
you're an investment bank with like 2
000 python programmers and you have
millions and millions and millions of
dollars every day writing
on this python code working if it works
now why would you touch it
right and what that means is you have
places that are running two four
places are running two six as a business
a continuum
we support we're not the only business
that does this right there are many
other companies that support these
things red hat actually
is a very large business that has to
support old python for a long time
so that's something we have to figure
out as a community i do think anaconda
and conda and like these nice packaging
environment things
are really going to help that a huge
amount
but but looking again 20 20 years in the
future i think people
there's always going to be need to
express your desires to the computer the
computer might get smarter smarter about
interpreting them
but i think people are always going to
want there's always a need for
that high level expression meeting the
business business is always going to
make first contact with computing
infrastructure
somewhere and at that junction is going
to be language
and whether language is python a variant
of python whether it's a weird julia r
python with a little bit of closure
script mixed in whatever it is
those things always have to be in
contact and um the reason why there
always has to be a language-based
approach i was talking to hadley wickham
actually at strata about this
great conversation and we both you know
he's kind of in the r world
our studio we're in the python world but
we both fundamentally believe in the
continuing demand for language-based
approaches um because if you have
the kinds of things you can express
their gui the kinds of things that you
can bottle up
and capture in a graphical interaction
are
going to be moving at a slower rate
they're going to be better understood
they're not those exploratory things
they're not cutting edge wiring in the
most cutting edge
infrastructure computational
infrastructure hardware what have you
the more things we have the more
heterogeneous our computing
infrastructure the more need we have for
languages
so i actually see more fragmentation
what we actually have right now
um i think we're coming to the end of
sort of a period of monoculture about a
20-year period of monoculture
between windows and linux and then x86
and so there's a lot more hardware
coming online vector processing is all
the rage again
all these things that were challenges in
the 70s and 80s are all of a sudden
relevant today
and so that period like in the um
there's a great term if i you know if i
take just a second of time
um there's a picture i show if people
are interested in this
you know what screw it i'm going to move
this to the other screen so i can
actually see it um
there's a there's a picture about um
this idea of dennard scaling
which is that you don't have the reason
we have
um
oh this will be embarrassing okay the
reason
that we have um the the the um fast
microprocessor through the 90s
is not because of moore's law but
actually because of the fact that we
were able to crank down the voltages
on transistors throughout that time so
we're able to cram more transistors into
a chip but at the same time we're able
to turn them all on
and therefore the chips got more
powerful and so software could just kind
of keep doing what it was
already doing um that that that dendrite
scaling is now
ended and that's why we don't have 10
gigahertz processors now is because
at those speeds at whatever the minimum
you know vdd is
you're going to burn out your chip like
the the heat density is greater than
like the surface temperature of the sun
and so you can't turn all the silicon on
at once so even at a chip level
you're configuring blocks of compute um
you're going to be writing software that
turns on this thing turns off the codec
turns this thing on
turns it off turns on this massive like
you know turns on the bitcoin miner bit
you know it turns that off that
configuration as
programming is not just again not hand
waving it's your reality right like the
phone
your phone if it was turning on all of
the silicon at once it would last like
10 minutes
right your phone has a video codec has a
gpu it's got all these things on it
all those things have to be configured
in software and that's gonna be the the
reality
of of computing for the foreseeable
future i think
so let's uh let's thank peter for a very
very interesting thought and a lot of
good insight so thank you very much
so we got lightning talks coming up in
this room so we're just going to set up
for that